I want to just start because I'm sure
you've been following this case with
your reaction when you heard the police
mention yesterday that um she was having
issues with the menopause
very honest when I heard it yesterday in
the police statement I was I was
horrified to hear that information that
people might choose to keep so personal
and so private was being shared so
publicly but today I have read the
statement from the family who tell us
that they were very aware that that was
being shared specifically to try to stop
some of the speculation and stories that
were being shared which they are finding
so hurtful yeah and a lot of those
stories of speculation being shared on
social media that we won't go anywhere
near on this program down but I mean in
your experience I mean have you met
individuals the family described her as
going into crisis because of the
perimenopause I know it's different for
everyone but have you met people who've
gone into crisis
right it is different for everyone
can't comment regarding Nicole I don't
know her or her family and I wouldn't
want to do that it would not be right to
do so but as far as other people are
concerned menopause is a very individual
experience one in four will have no
symptoms at all three out of four will
have symptoms and one in four will
describe those symptoms as debilitating
so significantly affecting their quality
of life and that could be physical
symptoms it could be cognitive things
like changes to memory and concentration
and equally it could be psychological
symptoms so things like increased
anxiety a feeling of flatness and low
mood perhaps changes to levels of
confidence so for some individuals they
certainly will experience as I say what
they would describe as a debilitating
time yeah and you say on your website
the hardest thing about menopause is not
having the right education and
information before it comes along I mean
what needs to be done to make sure that
people do have that info and the
education about it not just people who
who get the menopause but those of us
who who don't know and supporting people
who will have it
yeah absolutely and I'm so glad that
you've mentioned the people who don't
experience it too because you know half
of the population will experience
menopause directly the other half will
not go through their life without
knowing somebody who experiences
menopause so it's vital that we all have
a general understanding and back in 2018
I launched something called the make
menopause Mata Campaign which was
specifically aimed at improving
education for all of us so that we all
grow up having some idea of what
menopause is so we have campaigned for
menopause to be included in the school
curriculum successfully in England and
Scotland but we would also like to see
all of our GPS taught about menopause so
that they all have an understanding that
allows them to recognize what can be a
significant number of different symptoms
when their patients approach them
um and you know currently we're in a
situation where to be honest we have
done our medical health professionals a
huge disservice by not giving them that
education across the board and I would
also very much like to see this
government back a public health campaign
for menopause to bring education and
information to everybody
okay well they'll be watching we hope uh
Diane dancing bring do appreciate your
time and uh wish you all the very best
of luck in your work that message has
got out there loud and clear so thank
you very much this evening Diane thank
you